I mean it was it was the zombie
apocalypse by the time we left I was
living
um I was living in the Hollywood Hills
which is a very ritzy neighborhood uh
and by the time I left I was patrolling
my backyard at night with a gun to make
sure nobody had moved in uh you know I
had friends who had found homeless
people in their Apartments friends who
found them in their backyard and you
know it's nothing against the homeless
but there's nothing compassionate about
letting people live on the streets it's
not compassionate to them and it's not
compassionate to the people who come to
a city to find a way of life that's uh
you know Pleasant and uplifting I don't
think you can do that when your city is
overrun by people uh not just homeless
people but also criminals who are not
being restrained in any way it's it's
just amazing to me it is absolutely
amazing to me that a state like
California which is Paradise I mean if
you take the people out it's it's just
Paradise can be destroyed at that level
and yet people go on voting for the
people who destroyed it
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the host of the Andrew klavan show on
The Daily wire as well as author of the
brand new book a strange habit of Mind
Andrew Clavin welcome back to the Reuben
LaPorte great to see you Dave Andrew
you've done many things in your career
screenwriting many books daily wire but
you opened for me during the don't burn
this country book tour would you say
that was the highlight of the whole
operation and why even continue working
after that I I asked I struggled with
that question after uh opening through
your act I thought you know I'm now so
covered in shame that maybe there's no
no possibility of going on with any
self-respect at all but I've managed a
little bit how many books have you
written every time I bring you on I ask
you how many books and I'm still not
even sure how many books it's a lot of
books
well it's a lot of books the last book
when they published it they said it was
my 36 so I'm just going to go with that
wow I mean that that is really something
do you feel like each one when you
finish a book do you feel like it's your
last and then suddenly something the
well there's some more in the well or
how do you feel usually now the the only
time I ever thought of giving up was
after writing a book called Empire of
Lies which was a very difficult book and
a very emotional book and it really
wrecked me and I walked in and I said to
my wife that's it I'm done writing
novels and she said sit down and have
some dinner
you believe me even there wasn't even a
second where she thought that I might be
telling the truth it's kind of like an
addiction I can't stop all right so I
want to get into the book and I'm I so
we just got a copy this morning so in
full disclosure I have not read it yet
but I've read the synopsis here and
obviously between big Tech and
billionaires and Espionage and all sorts
of stuff there's a lot that's relevant
to our political stuff of the day so
they'll be there'll be plenty for us to
talk about but first off you you like me
and so many others are a California
expat you are a refugee of what is now I
would say communist California you're
feeling pretty good people do people
know publicly where you live sort of
roughly yeah I'm in I'm in Virginia in
the DC area and uh yeah it's the
smartest thing I ever did I mean it was
it was the zombie apocalypse by the time
we left I was living I'm I was living in
the Hollywood Hills which is a very
ritzy neighborhood uh and by the time I
left I was patrolling my backyard at
night with a gun to make sure nobody had
moved in uh you know I had friends who
had found homeless people in their
Apartments friends who found them in
their backyard and you know it's nothing
against the homeless but there's nothing
compassionate about letting people live
on the streets it's not compassionate to
them and it's not compassionate to the
people who come to a city to find a way
of life that's uh you know Pleasant and
uplifting I don't think you can do that
when your city is overrun by people uh
not just homeless people but also
criminals who are not being restrained
in any way it's it's just amazing to me
it is absolutely amazing to me that a
state like California which is Paradise
I mean if you take the people out it's
just Paradise can be destroyed at that
level and yet people go on voting for
the people who destroyed it I once asked
Larry Elder why he thought that was so
and he said they just don't connect the
policies to the apocalypse uh it's all
policy I mean if New York was like that
in the 80s and 90s when I lived there
and then Giuliani came in changed the
policies they called him a racist every
single day in the New York Times he
cleaned the city up and made it one of
the most beautiful cities uh at one of
the safest big cities in the world if
not the safest it took you know two
years to destroy all that work that was
kept in place by Bloomberg all those
years uh took just two years of
left-wing policies to destroy it it's
hard to understand like people will not
turn the corner I don't know whether
it's the feeling of virtue that leftism
gives them uh but it I I'm just so happy
to be out of that place it was
absolutely by the time do you see any
hope because uh you know we had a couple
dinners in La before before you left
first wisely and then I I followed a
couple months later but all of our
friends left and from everything I've
seen in the basically the nine or so
months that I've been gone it's just
getting worse I mean what how should we
feel the people that leave like should
we feel oh maybe they will turn it
around or should we be hopeful or is it
just like you know what enough already
that's what you guys want then just keep
running with that
well you know I always hope it is one of
the United States I always hope that
it'll come back uh you know online and
in the past because so much of the
industry is uh creative there's
Hollywood and there's uh you know
Silicon Valley so these are people who
are creative they're capitalists they
like to pretend they're not exactly they
have to make speeches at the Oscars
about not being capitalists but they're
the most capitalist people in the world
and so when their business gets undercut
to a certain degree you think that
they're going to come back and elect you
know a Reagan or uh you know even a
Schwarzenegger somebody to sort of
change things up the problem now is that
because we live in a world where we can
be connected like this like you and I
are connected right this minute there's
not that much uh difference if you leave
you can build an industry anywhere you
can run an industry from anywhere and so
my concern is that now people will
simply move uh you know to Nashville if
you go to Nashville everybody there is
from La uh you know people will simply
move to other places and just let the
place sink into the sea you think
eventually eventually the absolute
destruction of a brilliant economy
um we'll we'll back up on them you know
it just you think that people will only
stand it so long and yet the fact that
they have stood by well for instance San
Francisco one of the most beautiful
cities on Earth has been turned into a
hell hole is just amazing it is just
amazing so I don't know if it's going to
come back it's interesting because more
and more people are talking about what
is the United part of the United States
of America you know it's like I keep
saying it but I honestly feel like I
moved to a different country not to a
different state but to a different
country and and that I guess that leaves
us with the question of what makes us
United and I think there's a lot of you
know conservatives or whatever you want
to call broadly people on the right that
are just like there's nothing left
there's nothing left and that's it well
that that is the thing conservatives do
you know that's kind of a kind of a
knee-jerk thing conservative it's over
it's all over I give up and all this and
and you know when when Roe v Wade was
overturned I just reminded people you
know that things can change amazing work
can be done it takes a long time it took
the left 60 years to take over our
institutions and bring the country this
low uh it's going to be a long fight to
take it back but it can be done my hope
is that we become more Federalist uh we
we let the states it be independently
become Laboratories of democracy try
different things and that as we do that
the good ideas will spread the
alternative scenario to that is we
become more Federalist we split apart
and eventually we find ourselves at each
other's throats uh but I but I hope
that's not going to happen in fact one
of the things that I hope will help is
the repeal of Roe v Wade I hope that
because of that cultures are going to
form that attract and repel people and I
think that you know right now it's the
economy people go places for the jobs
they go places to get away from the
homeless from the crime time but soon
people are going to go places to live
with other people like themselves and uh
as as one way of living works better
than others I think maybe more States
will turn over we'll see
you know I should tell you that here in
Miami I did finally see one person with
the Charlie Crist sign and I almost
knocked on their door and offered them
free Mental Health Services for a year
it's like what are you doing you're here
in heaven and you've got the Charlie
that's the big fear that they'll bring
California with them if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell